meagan Markel spotted for the first time  since prince harry relationship rumors  started heating up the American actress  known for her role as Rachel Zane was  back on the set of suits Wednesday in  Toronto  Botox caught Megan smiling from ear to  ear as she stepped out of her home for a  night shoot sporting a black coat beanie  hat and sunglasses a source told et the  32 year old royal made a secret visit to  Canada where his rumoured girlfriend is  filming before flying back to the UK and  apparently Harry's new rumored romance  is off to a good start  the source adds quote Megan has met  Harry's close inner circle of friends  they really like her and like that he is  happy - really good to see how  compatible they are or are not